David Beckham can p anywhere as soon as
you get a if as soon as you get a corner
you're actually looking at a goal really
David Beckham in terms of dead bull
specialist yeah I know we got the ward
presses now we've had the janinos we've
had some Specialists right but he's the
original let's let's not let's not let's
not mess us up and he doesn't get the
credit he deserves when you speak to
xpros they say just how good he is one
touch in possession getting about the
pitch he wasn't just a free kick
Merchant and if we're talking about
iconic footballers rockar footballers
yes we had talk about Off Pitch stuff
bro he married a spice gu and I know
this is not probably football and stuff
but it's important and one of the main
Spice Girls as yeah yeah and he bro he
was in the audience for the you know the
wedding the king you know like the king
and queens wedding he's there they bring
him in yeah this guy's a whole legend he
has to be there and even after football
go look he bought a whole team into
Miami and look what Messi's doing
because he's David Beckham he signed
he's signed one of the goats that makes
him a goat already it does